قبيله بدء الحرب في اوكرانيا اجرت
بيلاروسيا مناورات عسكريه مشتركه مع
حليفتها روسيا التي كانت ان اذن بصدد
الحشد العسكري على الحدود الاوكرانيه
تمهيد للحرب ومع بدايه المعارك في الرابع
والعشرين من فبراير شكلت بيلاروسيا نقطه
عبور للقوات الروسيه الى المناطق الشماليه
الاخرانيه وقاعده خلفيه لشن الهجمات على
العاصمه كياب كما فتحت المجال الجويه امام
الطائرات والصواريخ الروسيه
ورغم ذلك كانت بلا روسيا اول من قدم منصه
للتفاوض بين الروس والاوكرانيين على امل
التوسل الى تسويه سياسيه فجرت جولتان من
المفاوضات بين ال 28 من فبراير والثامن من
مارس في مدينتين جمل وبليس البيلاروسيتين
مع اوكرانيا
لكنني حاولت الحفاظ على حد الادنى من
العلاقات مع كلاب بتركيز على المساعده
الانسانيه لطرفي الحرب واستقبال اللاجئين
شاركت في مناورات عسكريه جديده مع روسيا
اواخر شهر ابريل استمرت اربعه ايام
توارى الدور البيلاروسي في خضاب تطورات
الحرب بعد ذلك لا سيما بعد الانسحاب
الروسي من وسط اوكرانيا وتركز المعارك في
المقاطعات الشرقيه لكنه عاد بقوه بعد حادث
التفجير في جسر القرن في الثامن من اكتوبر
الماضي فبعد يومين من الحادث زار بوتين
العاصمه منسك واتفق مع نظيره البيلاروسي
الكسندر لوكاشيكو على انشائي قوات اقليميه
مشتركه انضم اليها الاف المجند الى الروس
اثار ذلك مخاوف من احتمال انخراف القوات
البيلاروسيه في الحرب على اوكرانيا خاصه
في ظل الضغط الذي كانت تواجهه حينها القوه
الروسيه في المناطق الشرقيه الاوكرانيه
ويعتقد ان هدف الروسي كان اجبار الجيش
الاوكراني على سحب جزء من قوته نحو الشمال
لتخفيف الضغط عن القوه الروسيه
عاد بوتين الى العاصمه البيلاروسيا في
التاسعه عشر من ديسمبر ورات كياب في ذلك
ما يستدعي القلق من احتمال شن هجمات على
اوكرانيا من الاراضي البيلاروسيا مع بدايه
العام الجديد تماما كما حدث في بدايه
الحرب لكن الكريم للوصف هذه المزاعم بالا
اساس لها